peux pas vous dire que ça me réjouissent
de voir les socialistes éliminés de ce
département je gardais encore un petit
espoir mais objectivement les résultats
illustrent très très bien la dérive
actuelle de la vie politique
il y a une liste tout à fait sérieuse et
ancré sur le territoire c'est celle que
mener gérard larcher et il remporte le
les gains de son action par ailleurs
cette multiplicité de liste apparu dans
toute son absurdité dans toute son
absurdité quand on voit des candidats
qui réunissait une trentaine de voix sur
leur nom se dit qu'il aurait pu
réfléchir et aller plutôt renforcé leur
famille politique pour peu qu'il en est
une
voilà donc cette cette division est
mortel et on arrive au bout de ce
constat on a comme l'impression lors ce
qu'on regarde les les premiers résultats
qui s'affine
de plus en plus la droite j'ai à dire
consolide plus ou moins ses positions le
parti socialiste
j'allais dire sauve les meubles une
certaine manière la république en marche
a beaucoup de mal visiblement à rentrer
dans ce palais du luxembourg c'est sûr
ça n'est pas son élection l'élection
sénatoriale pour un mouvement qui vient
de naître et qui n'a pas d'élus locaux
donc là ça illustre aussi la spécificité
de cette élection sénatoriale
c'est à dire que sont élus les élus qui
ont une vraie expérience locale une
vraie présence locale et qui se sont
battus pour leur département parce que
même parmi les nouveaux élus que vous
avez cités ce sont des gens qui étaient
très présents dans le département des
yvelines et dont on connaît les
engagements et l'action c'est vrai que
la droite tire les marrons du feu de
cette situation absurde d'extrême
division clairement
à la dernière élection sénatoriale
j'avais fait une liste de rassemblement
cette fois ci c'est une liste purement
socialiste et on voit ce que ça donne